Speaker 1: Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
has pulled a disgusting political stunt
that actually isn't that terrible for some of
the people involved. And I'll explain that in a
moment. But the big headline is that Ron DeSantis
flew 50 migrants to the swanky island of Martha's
Vineyard. And this is really just a sick political
stunt. It's meant to trigger and own the libs and
on and on and on. But I'm going to argue that this
is actually quite the opposite. A Business Insider
has a report about this. DeSantis sent 50 migrants
to Martha's Vineyard by plane as an anti-liberal
stunt. The locals pulled together to help
them. Now, I've spent a lot of time on Martha's
Vineyard, and as soon as I saw the headlines, my
instinct was, I don't know that this is going to
work out necessarily the way Ron DeSantis imagines
it working out, because Martha's Vineyard is very,
very liberal, extraordinarily liberal. And it
only follows logically that you are going to
see the people of Martha's Vineyard come together
to help these 50 individuals. As the story goes,
Governor, this is Business Insider. Governor Ron
DeSantis of Florida sent planeloads of migrants
to Martha's Vineyard in Massachusetts. It was
apparently intended to shift some of the burden
of migration to a rich liberal area. Locals at
the exclusive destination where Barack Obama
owns property rallied to help out. State Senator
Julian Cyr of Massachusetts told The New York
Times about 50 migrants arrived in two planes
with no warning. Fox News Digital reported the
story and had video of migrants disembarking
from planes. All right. You can imagine what it
looks like for people to get off of a plane. Yes,
Florida can confirm the two planes with illegal
immigrants that arrived in Martha's Vineyard
today were part of the state's relocation program
to transport illegal immigrants to sanctuary
destinations. That's Taryn Fenske, the comms
director for DeSantis. And then you just have to
look at the reaction from the island of Martha's
Vineyard, Fernandez posting. Our island jumped
into action, putting together 50 beds, giving
everyone a good meal, providing a play area for
the children, making sure people have the health
care and support they need. We are a community
that comes together to support immigrants.
Another article from KBS, Florida's DeSantis flies
dozens of illegal immigrants to Martha's Vineyard,
escalating tactic against, quote, sanctuary
destinations. Think about how absurd this is.
First of all, Florida spends a bunch of money to
fly people out. These folks appear to actually
have come from Texas, not even from Florida. So
it's like, why is Ron DeSantis even involved? Why
is taxpayer money being spent to move people from
Texas to Massachusetts? That doesn't even make
sense first and foremost. Secondly, from a fiscal
conservatism point of view, I think it would have
been cheaper for Florida to set up temporary
housing and vocational training for these folks,
eventually making them a productive, taxpaying
component of the Florida economy, rather than
just blowing a few million dollars of taxpayer
money to fly people from Texas to Massachusetts
for a political stunt. And by the way, if these
folks eventually want to go back to Texas,
they're going to be able to do it and nothing's
going to stop them. And Ron DeSantis isn't going
to track them down and fly them out again. So
it's not only absurd, sort of superficially,
but it doesn't even make sense in terms of a
political stunt with taxpayer money now. In the
meantime, the migrants are now in Martha's
Vineyard rather than Florida or Texas, and
statistically, without casting any aspersions or
judgment, without making any moral statement. If
you look at the HDI, that's the human development
index of Massachusetts, Florida and Texas,
which is a metric that considers a number of
different types of well-being. The migrants
are certainly far better off in Massachusetts than
they would be in Florida or Texas, but that's sort
of a different story. And then the last kind of
absurd or ironic component of this is that when
Ron DeSantis pulls these stunts and sends people
from red states to blue states, or when Abbott
Greg Abbott, the governor of Texas Republican,
has also pulled these types of stunts before.
Aren't you incentivizing immigration because
you're sending the signal to migrants undocumented
immigration? That would be you're sending the
signal to migrants. Hey, listen, even if where
you would manage to get is Texas, which I mean,
you know, just look at the data. Texas is no, it's
no beauty when it comes to access to health care,
education, quality, all these different things.
You get yourself to taxes will get you to a
much better state by most metrics. By pulling
this stunt, you're arguably incentivizing the
very undocumented immigration that you want to
disincentivize by saying, we'll upgrade you to a
state with higher income, more access to health
care, better infrastructure and better education.
They claim to want to disincentivize that very
undocumented immigration. It's a pathetic stunt.
I don't know what this does to public opinion,
to an empirical question. We have to wait
and see. But by every metric, we can measure
a very stupid stunt. Let me know your thoughts.
Maybe I'm missing something. Find me on Twitter
at David Pakman. Also, remember that Monday, 919,
just four days away, we are doing our blowout
historic membership special. If you've been
thinking of becoming a member. This is a perfect
time to do it. Get on my newsletter at David
Pakman dot com and then Monday morning you will
get a perfect email telling you exactly how to
avail yourself of this great membership discount.